[Music]
on this wednesday night
the pandemic the parties and public
trust
the politician who broke the rules we
all have to do better
and the difficulties of connecting all
the contacts to contain the spread the
road to economic recovery
why the feds say now's the time to spend
money
risky reveling during a world series win
the base for a possible super spreader
celebration
and filling a much needed void and then
say
wow it's really this is my skin the
artist
brightening the lives of all amputees
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
the message that we have to reduce our
social interactions to limit the spread
of kova 19
is clear but not everyone is heeding
that warning there have been more than
36
000 new cases across canada in the past
two weeks
that's more than we recorded in the
first 12 weeks
since the novel coronavirus arrived in
the country contact tracing is proving
difficult in some provinces
as people mask their behavior as mike
delay explains
it's hard to convince the public to
follow the rules when political leaders
aren't leading by example on
thanksgiving ontarians were told to keep
their gatherings small
and on halloween kids in several regions
won't be allowed to trick-or-treat
sacrifices ontario premier doug ford
said that were for the greater good
yet this week one of his mpp sam
usterhoff
was outed for hosting a 40-person dinner
in a private room at a restaurant
nary a mask could be seen and when told
to wear them he and his group
said no and when pressed on the issue
ford said an apology was enough
we all have to do better i have to do
better sam has to do better
not surprisingly ford is getting an
earful on social media
and while this is a single isolated case
most of the responses
raise the question of an erosion in
public trust i think that
the majority of people would like to do
the right thing but what is the right
thing to do that message is getting
confusing and is um
you know in in some ways not really
making a lot of sense
and epidemiologists say that public
confusion is already having a negative
impact on measures like mask wearing and
distancing
people's social gatherings which in turn
damages the efficiency of contact
tracing
which relies on memory and honesty i
think people are
whether it's shame or whether it's fear
of of
a penalty but are not reporting who
they've contacted have not reporting
where they may have come in contact with
the virus because
some people may not want to admit they
were at a social gathering or at
a specific event there have been so many
cases in toronto
contact tracing is now only being done
for outbreaks
and in alberta health officials haven't
been able to narrow down
where 43 of new cases originated
it's a problem says craig jenny that's
ultimately
up to all of us to fix one thing we can
control
in this whole pandemic is our behavior
and it seems like
in many instances we're simply choosing
not to mike dralet global news toronto
here's a look at the numbers across
canada today there were more than 800
new cases in ontario in quebec
more than 900 new cases and 17 more
deaths
there were 287 new cases today in bc
410 in alberta 67 in saskatchewan
and manitoba reported nearly 170
new infections with case numbers rising
quickly in that province
the chief nursing officer is warning
hospitals are starting to feel the
strain
our icu i just checked before we came in
is around 92 percent occupancy which was
higher
than on monday and i can also report
that we have canceled 43 surgeries
as of today there are 89 people in
hospital in manitoba
19 of them in intensive care the
province's top doctor says many new
cases have been linked back to
thanksgiving
he's urging people not to throw
halloween parties
the federal public health agency is
warning of the far-reaching consequences
of covet-19 in canada
in its annual report the agency says the
pandemic has had a profound
impact on canadians well-being people
have reported
exercising less and drinking more the
opioid crisis is escalating and mental
health issues
are on the rise all canadians are
feeling the impact but it's been
hardest on seniors essential workers
racialized canadians
women and people with disabilities dr
theresa tam is calling for
structural change to address
inequalities
the virus didn't create new inequities
in our society it
exposed them these findings are more
than just uncomfortable facts about our
country during this pandemic
they are the lived realities of
countless canadians
in terms of canada's financial health
we're getting a better sense of how long
it might take to recover from covet 19.
the bank of canada is keeping its
benchmark interest rate at 0.25 percent
and it plans to keep it there until 2023
for more on the forecast and the factors
at play let's bring in david aiken in
ottawa
david what is the government banking on
to get the economy back on track
well robin if you wanted to buy that new
car or do some home renovations or maybe
borrow a bit more to get yourself
through the next few months go ahead the
bank of canada has got your back
if you're a household considering making
a major purchase
if you're a business considering
investing
you can be confident that interest rates
will be low for a long time
once upon a time bank of canada
governors worried about ballooning
household debt
no longer this one tiff macklin wants
canadians to spend
and that's why the bank took the
extraordinary step wednesday of all but
guaranteeing that interest rates will
remain as low as possible
until 2023 we do think it's important
to be as clear as we can about how we
see things today
that will help canadians make the
decisions that they need to make
consumer spending was the key to the
recent reopening recovery and
it will be vital in the months ahead we
expect consumption to be the
the leading driver of the recovery so
while the bank of canada does
its part to make it as easy as possible
to borrow and spend
it will be up to the federal government
to provide income support programs for
consumers
and businesses and on wednesday the
government indicated
it will do just that we are first and
foremost
a country of survivors
and one of the first lessons of survival
is that you must do
whatever it takes whatever you can
when the wolf is at the door deputy
prime minister and finance minister
christian freeland says
the details will come later but it is
clear that consumer and business income
support programs
will not only continue they may be
enhanced doing too little
is more dangerous and potentially more
costly
than doing too much but all that
spending so far has not been enough or
not in time
to save many of the country's businesses
statistics canada reported today that
between march and july
more than eighty thousand businesses
that's about ten percent of all the
businesses in the country
have shut their doors robin david aiken
in ottawa thanks david
migrants working in caregiving and
domestic roles in this country
are facing job insecurity and are
vulnerable to exploitation
200 care workers many of whom live in
their employers homes
responded to a survey from the migrants
rights network
nearly half say coven 19 shutdowns
resulted in them working longer hours
with fewer days off
40 percent of respondents say they
didn't get paid for the additional labor
the stress on these workers is being
made worse by employers
limiting their movement one-third
reported not being allowed to leave the
home
not even to send money to support family
members in their home countries
the migrants rights network also says
care workers who have lost their jobs
during the pandemic
face roadblocks and finding new work
because of the long and arduous process
of applying
for a new work permit 16 bc firefighters
who tested positive for kova 19
are under quarantine tonight after
returning home from the front lines
in california the bc wildfire service
says three initial cases were reported
in the u.s
13 more were confirmed after crews
returned home
it's unclear how the first three were
infected but contact tracing
is now underway 223 bc firefighters were
sent to california to help with the
state's
worst wildfire season on record
more than 7.5 million people in
california alone
have voted early in the u.s presidential
election
they're among the record 75 million
americans
who've already cast ballots nationwide
voters are keen to get the results but
every state has its own rules when it
comes to processing and counting
mail-in ballots jackson proskow reports
on the looming chaos
in the final count in pennsylvania
they've already received
2 million mail-in ballots the monumental
task of opening and counting them can't
begin
until election day we have to be patient
people have to know the system is
different in different
states the three states that decided the
last election
will be the last to start counting their
mail-in ballots
the result may be no result for days
wisconsin says it won't count all its
ballots until november 4th
michigan and pennsylvania say it could
take until friday november 6 to declare
a winner
there are some states where you might
see president trump winning
on election night or early on election
night but once these mail-in ballots are
counted
even the next day or a day later that
they could switch
the potential confusion cuts both ways
the in-place states that could decide
the presidency quickly
do allow for an early count arizona
florida and north carolina will deliver
the bulk of mail-in and in-person
results on election night
it would be very very proper and very
nice if
a winner were declared on november 3rd
there are fears trump may seek to
exploit delays that are already
built into the system even though states
have weeks to certify their results
you may have president trump declare
victory on the first day if he is ahead
in some states and then he may then say
that it's fraudulent
as the absentee ballots are counted
there are also fears of potential court
challenges targeting the results
a decisive win by either candidate makes
that less likely
the bigger worry may be all the ballots
that are still outstanding
states are waiting on millions of them
to be returned amidst new warnings about
heavy delays with the u.s postal system
americans are now being urged to drop
off their ballots in person
to add a little certainty to this
uncertain election
robin jackson frosco in washington
thanks jackson
kova 19 is a major issue in the final
stretch of the campaign
and both candidates have very different
approaches to the health crisis
as mike armstrong reports from west
virginia there's a huge difference
between
how their supporters see it too
this state is about as red as they get
the latest poll in west virginia gives
donald trump a two to one advantage
it's not that there aren't many biden
signs here there aren't even many trump
signs the campaign doesn't need them
i feel confident yeah gail hartley is
doing her part with the trump flag
and jokes that west virginians sort of
get ignored during presidential
elections
i think the last presidential candidate
we had was george bush
that's a while ago that's a while ago we
don't we don't see them
now what this state has in common with
others is its
struggle with covet 19. the seven day
average of positive tests has jumped
close to 50 percent over the last three
weeks
there's a severe upswing west virginia
has 10 days of early voting at one point
they had to close a polling station
after a polling worker tested positive
despite that when the president
complains about
coverage of covet 19. covert covent
covey cover cook
covered covent co-man his supporters
here
tend to agree the media has blown it out
of proportion
i truly feel like he's trying to keep
the country from uh
panicking over it to be quite honest
with you well i've seen
very few people sick and i've seen a lot
of people broke
economically it's been devastating now
as americans cast their ballots the
difference in how supporters of the
candidates
view the pandemic is striking when asked
about various issues there's always a
gap
but it's usually small according to a
recent poll on foreign policy
50 percent of biden voters say it's very
important versus 53 percent of trump
voters
they're close on abortion they're even
close on supreme court appointments
but on the coronavirus outbreak it's a
massive gap
82 percent of biden supporters say it
was very
important to their vote but only 24
of trump supporters we have a spike
that said in a close election even
turning a small number of republicans
away from trump can make a difference
there's a reason the president's been
desperate to change the conversation
covert covert covert he's complaining
and his critics have pushed it hard
the more we're talking about it the
worse it becomes for donald trump the
fact that he himself was diagnosed with
it
i was not a great look for his campaign
now there is another way the pandemic
has hurt trump his strongest argument
going into this campaign
would have been the economy well the
bottom's fallen out of that because of
covet 19.
trump still pushes it but instead of
saying look what we built
he has to say we'll build it again robin
mike armstrong in west virginia thanks
mike
the los angeles dodgers won the world
series for the first time since 1988
but a player is making even bigger
headlines
justin turner was removed from play
during the eighth inning after receiving
a positive covid test
but the third baseman turned up later
for post-game celebrations
hoisting the trophy embracing a teammate
imposing masculists for team photos
he's also sitting next to manager dave
roberts who's a cancer survivor
the democrats are desperate to win the
white house but winning the senate
is critical too we'll explain coming up
the u.s election has 35 senate seats up
for grabs these are critical to both
parties and as eric sorensen reports
democrats hope to win a hat trick on
election night the white house the house
of representatives
and the senate in georgia this week
joe biden had more on his mind than the
presidency
let's give the people of georgia two new
senators the u.s
senate is a crucial part of biden's
expanding game
plan not just to win but to have the
power to govern effectively
after he wins it's a travesty a travesty
democrats could only watch in
frustration this week as the
republican-dominated senate confirmed
president trump's
third conservative supreme court nominee
they won't be able to do much about this
for a long time to come democrats
control the house of representatives but
to push an agenda forward
biden needs the senate given the degree
of polarization we see in the u.s
without support in both houses of
congress a president really can't
legislate
the republicans currently hold a 53-47
advantage in the u.s senate
to gain control the democrats need a net
gain of three
or four if joe biden loses because the
vice president breaks a tie in the
senate
every two years roughly a third of the
senate seats are contested this year 35
races
most are republicans in red you can take
many of those off the map because they
are considered safe for re-election
and of the 12 democratic seats in blue
all but about two
are also considered safe so where does
that leave us well the democrats will
probably lose in alabama
but they could win in arizona in
colorado in maine
in north carolina and in a few other
competitive races
the bottom line is there are many more
opportunities to turn
red republican seats into blue
democratic seats republican senators
suddenly find themselves being dragged
down
by the top of the ticket i felt kind of
bad after the first debate quite frankly
lindsey graham is down to the wire
against democrat jamie harrison
in south carolina what should be a
secure republican seat
and arizona republican martha mcsally
even dodged questions about donald trump
senator the question was are you proud
of your support
for president trump i'm proud to be
fighting for arizona every single day
is that a yes or no for president
legislation the president deflects
suggestions that some senators could
lose
because they're tied to him i probably
helped some
i don't think i heard anybody but i
don't i don't view them as being tied
together i never did
on election night a bigger win for
democrats than running up the score for
biden
would be squeaking out a second victory
taking over the u.s senate
eric sorenson global news don
masinkowski a longtime conservative from
alberta who served in parliament for 25
years
has died i now invite honourable members
to rise
in the house of commons a moment of
silence in his honor
masinkowski served as a cabinet minister
under two prime ministers
joe clark and brian mulroney and as
deputy prime minister from 1986 to 1993
mazinkowski passed away tuesday night at
the age of 85.
back under lockdown ahead a surge in
coba 19 cases
forces france to bring in new
restrictions
france has announced a second national
lockdown banning travel between regions
beginning friday people will only be
allowed to leave home for essential work
to buy essential goods
or seek medical attention or exercise
for one hour
businesses such as restaurants and bars
will close on tuesday france recorded
523 new coronavirus deaths
the country's highest number since late
april
germany reported a record 14 964 new
cova cases
only around 25 of germany's intensive
care beds are still available
the rise in infections has prompted a
new partial lockdown
beginning november 2nd restaurants and
bars will close except for takeout
live theater and movie theaters will
shut there will be no crowds at sports
events and those who can work from home
are being encouraged to do so up next
crafting change how a nigerian man's
work is increasing
inclusivity
every year thousands of canadians lose a
limb
the experience is traumatic and has a
profound impact on a person's life
an artificial limb is usually a major
part of the recovery process
but for someone who isn't white it can
be hard and expensive to find one that
matches their skin tone
crystal commansing has the story of a
nigerian man who is trying to make the
industry
more inclusive hands breasts ears
any body part needed john sande is ready
to create it
he's an industrial fine artist but his
work took him in a new direction
about three years ago when his brother
lost fingers in an
accident his option for a prosthesis
was a white hat this behavior changed
know this guy is not happy
and god forbid he could have taken his
life maybe
so i had to do something fast and quick
the global prosthetics industry
is expanding to include more skin tones
but it's a relatively
small industry product availability is
based on demand and the cost of
manufacturing
on volume the war amps says a non-white
amputee
can end up spending more for a
prosthesis there aren't any
sort of off-the-shelf options but what
the company can do
is paint the color or or do a customized
version but then that can get very
expensive annalise petlock says
health coverage for canadians depends on
what province you live in
war amps through its key tag donation
program helps cover
some of the costs for children and
adults but
many people still end up having to
fundraise
a prosthetic leg that starts above the
knee for example
can cost sixty thousand dollars you
should be able to
get a limb that matches your skin tone
and that allows you to replicate some of
the function that you've lost
and right now the way that the funding
is across the country
we're being restricted pat lock who is
also an amputee
says provincial governments need to
increase funding to better support
amputees
sande has seen how the right prosthesis
can change a life
they hug me some have to hug me for
minutes
and then say wow it's really this is my
skin this is my skin this is my skin
and i just feel satisfied you know his
brother michael
is also satisfied and much happier with
the hand
his brother created for him crystal
gamansen global news
london and that is global national for
this wednesday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is ottawa thank you
for watching
and i'll see you back here tomorrow have
a great night